welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Professor Paul Saban associate
professor of history his research and
teaching focus on energy and
environmental history today we'll talk
with Professor Sabin about his new book
the bet Paul Ehrlich Julian Simon and
our gamble over Earth's future it
provides a framework for understanding
today's environmental debates
welcome professor saiva thanks so much
for having me let's start with an
overview of the book and of course tell
us the story about the bet sure well the
the book is uses an iconic bet between
the biologist Paul Ehrlich who is the
author of the 1968 blockbuster the
Population Bomb and and one of his main
critics a man named Julian Simon and
economist and they actually made a bet
in 1980 about five metals and their
prices and whether they would go up or
down over the course of the next ten
years and this was a proxy for their
arguments about overpopulation and
whether the world was headed for famine
resource scarcity war thermonuclear war
or or disease outbreaks and these have
been some of the predictions that
Ehrlich had made and Simon had argued in
fact that human ingenuity and innovation
would lead to overpopulation or
population growth not being ultimately a
problem okay so so science will alert
Simon a bit and and ever since people
arguing about what this what the outcome
of the bet means so he the the five
metals their copper a chromium nickel
tin and tungsten may declined pretty
much across the board Ehrlich ultimately
sent Simon a check for five hundred and
seventy six dollars to represent his the
decline in value of the the bundle of
metals that they had that they had bet
on and so the question is what does this
bet bet mean I mean metal prices aren't
necessarily the best proxy for the state
of humanity or the environmental
condition I was curious as to why they
chose metals I mean you know what is
relevancy of them right well I mean if
you situated in the late 1970s and think
of
about the the run-up in oil prices and
the oil shocks at that time and there
also was significant increase in prices
of metals at that time so there there
was a lot of focus on commodities and
commodity prices and the idea that there
we were headed towards scarcity so there
have been predictions in the early 70s
that we were gonna run out of oil during
the 1980s and that turned out not to be
the case
so so so the part of why I was
interested in this in this story coming
at it from an environmental history
perspective was that Simon won the bet
and trying to understand you know what
can we learn from from his victory over
overall look in this case I mean just to
expound on on what led you to write the
book I mean so how did you I mean is
this bet well known yeah well it has
become a significant touchstone for
particularly for conservatives
criticizing environmentalists over
environmental regulation actually the
Competitive Enterprise Institute offers
an award each year the Julian Simon
award for for innovators for for people
who focus on human innovation and and
the award trophy is a leaf that has the
five medals that were from the bet so I
guess it's sort of symbolic of how
Simon's victory has been a touchstone
and so it's seeing that if that these
predictions of population growth we're
perhaps mistaken then that also means
the various other kinds of environmental
concerns also maybe our mistake and
that's that's been the argument you must
in in terms of writing this book you
know looked back and have seen some
predictions back in the day that were
made that didn't necessarily pan out was
there anything that was particularly
surprising to you well I was surprised
and so to see how widely held some of
these predictions were about that we
were gonna run out of oil or in the late
60s this tremendous fears of worldwide
famine that was about to strike the
planet and and then some of the some of
the claims that were made based on that
also were striking us there was a book
that was published in the late 60s
called famine 1975 that argued that
there's going to be worldwide famines as
a result of overpopulation and food
shortages and and therefore we should
practice tree
and some some countries were seen as
being kind of beyond the pale unsavable
and that we should cut them off from
food aid and so some of some of the
arguments were pretty extreme in terms
of what we needed to do to avoid the
future crises it must have been somewhat
amusing to to have read some of them
interesting to see these predictions and
and and how they haven't turned out as
expected I mean so my book is called the
bet because of this little bit but it's
also another meaning of the title is
that we're all engaged in the bet today
about the future and so some of these
predictions haven't come true to date
but it doesn't mean that difficult times
or major challenges won't face us in the
future so I guess many of these issues
aren't entirely resolved so what do we
face in the future
well I'm most interested in the debate
over climate change right now and seeing
how that's unfolding and one of the
things that I think is interesting about
this earlier story about population
growth and resource scarcity is how the
debate today over climate change is kind
of stuck in ruts that were established
by the earlier fight between Simon and
Ehrlich and their allies and so you see
today accusations of alarmism about
about the climate on one side and great
skepticism about science by many
conservatives and part of that is drawn
from their previous criticisms over
about population growth than resource
scarcity now those things didn't turn
out the way that was expected but I
think climate change in fact is
happening and is a grave concern and
it's really unfortunate that we're stuck
in these these long-standing grunts yeah
I mean I have read that pretty much most
scientists will agree that there is
climate change going on that it is
happening so do you argue in your book
something along the lines of how - you
know what we need to do well I mean the
argument of the book is is one that we
need to recognize how these two extreme
perspectives in some ways produced each
other and and that and then also we need
to figure out what can we learn from
both sides so I guess I see that both
Ehrlich's perspective and Simon's
arguments have important insights to
share or that yes so Ehrlich's on on the
way that humans are transforming the
planet the tremendous impact that we
have many of the biological changes that
are unfolding but Simon's about the
adaptability of human society of
flexibility of human economies the role
of innovation and technology and science
all those things that that that mean
that we aren't on a straight line I
guess from abundance to scarcity as many
people who are predicting we were gonna
run out of various resources they said
we were gonna go you know from abundant
oil all of a sudden to scarcity but in
fact it's really a history of boom and
bust over over over the X of the whole
history of the oil economy and and so I
guess learning from both sides and I
think that's one of the essential points
in terms of learning from Julian Simon's
point of view he argued that problems
often led to solutions that ultimately
led us better off and my own view about
the climate story is that it's only by
recognizing that climate change is a
problem that we can unleash the
solutions that Julian Simon celebrated
and so one of the problems that we face
right now is that in their reluctance to
recognize that climate change is a
problem many of Simon's Ally
intellectual allies are in some ways
undermining the very kinds of solutions
that Simon celebrated well wouldn't
couldn't one argue that there are
certain people who recognize that
there's climate change but the people
who don't want to recognize it have a
financial gain so that's part of the
problem isn't it well it is true that
there are powerful financial interests
actually on all sides of this of this
story I mean and but my my book is more
about the intellectual battle and and
recognize an exit there are important
insights on both sides it's not just a
financial fight I mean they're there
that is very important the oil oil
fossil fuel industries are very powerful
and have deep vested interest in in
sustaining the fossil fuel economy but
at the same time the whole debate is
actually embedded in this larger clash
over how we think about the future
mm-hmm okay so how do you think we
should think about the future
well I'm cautiously optimistic about
about the future recognizing that we
have major challenges ahead but that I
think if we if we if we take the steps
necessary to address them we can
overcome them and
the case of climate change the major the
major steps would be bringing bringing
climate into the into the marketplace
actually to the extent through through
carbon taxes or through kind of
regulatory systems like cap-and-trade
but that there'd be some way to put the
power of human innovation and and
markets to bear on the on the carbon
dioxide the climate problem and that
really what the problem we have right
now is that it's it's sort of
free-floating outside of the marketplace
and there's no way to bring our the
powerful forces we have to bear on
solving it you know I I wonder is there
going to be a point of no return where
everyone keeps talking talking talking
and not doing anything and then it
becomes too late and then I think about
population at being at what seven
billion now I mean how many more people
can the earth carry right well that's
interesting I mean I think that there's
really a distinction between population
growth and climate change are somewhat
different because climate change
produces a kind of environmental
outcomes rising sea levels at
acidification of the ocean they're very
it's likely linked to extreme or extreme
weather there there's specific things
that come whereas I think population
growth is kind of results in the kind of
different kinds of diffuse pressures
that are felt by the marketplace and so
there are many different ways to solve
the problems that are the challenges the
population growth poses so I don't think
that we're gonna run to the point where
one more person or a certain number of
people are going to lead us over the
cliff on population but I think and
climate actually it is more that's a
little less clear in terms of how that's
going to unfold and and there are
possibly tipping points with the climate
and we don't entirely understand the
climate system and how it will develop
and so that's those are the kinds of
risks and uncertainties that the kind of
bet that we're making right now that we
need to address so how do we address my
mean what's the first step
well like as I was saying I think it's
really about putting a price on carbon
on trying to bring the the problems
associated with with global warming into
the into market framework where we can
be bringing the
kind of forces to bear on solving them
the kind of innovation that Julian Simon
celebrated will only happen if we can
create the proper incentives for people
to be innovating and taking action so I
think it's really about a partnership
between government and and the
marketplace and that the marketplace
needs to be structured in a way that if
it kind of furthers the values that we
have the kind of society we want to live
in well hopefully that will happen
sooner rather than constantly optimistic
but there are a lot of reasons not to be
- okay thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work thanks so much for having me for
more information about Professor Sabin
and his work please visit our website at
Yale edu slash macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Centre for International
and area studies at you